this is a woman 26 years old look at
what it says i now know that i am not a
trans man she underwent double
mastectomy and hormone therapy to become
male after just two hours
two hours of counseling tells of her
regret as she begins
detransitioning back to female
okay there's a whole movement out there
of people that are de-transitioning who
are coming out now i don't know if
you've heard this it was in some of the
people were in um matt walsh's was a
woman documentary i don't know if you
saw it it's interesting no matter where
you stay on the issue
there are people now coming out and
saying
i was able to go private this particular
woman originally went through the nhs
national health service of england
that's government-run healthcare and
they told her there was going to be a
wait so she said oh i don't want to wait
i'm going to go private and was able to
have that minimal amount of time
conversation with somebody
and they say okay
winds up getting a double mastectomy and
then
panics a short time after and realizes
okay this is not right this is not what
i want to do and doesn't go through with
the remainder of the surgery and now is
out there warning people and saying
think about this and even goes on to
tell the story about how
you know she was in a world where she
was looking online and seeing people
that felt out of place people people
that felt out of their element and was
thinking well maybe that's me
maybe that's me and now is encouraging
people to get a substantial amount of
therapy do a substantial amount of
thinking
get a substantial amount of counseling
to figure out what is really at the root
of what's going on there don't forget to
hit subscribe and hit like if you like
the discussion that we're having right
now
these people have been silenced that
have de-transitioned
they're repeatedly silenced they're
labeled bigots she goes on to say in
that article even that she has been
referred to as anti-trans now
has to deal with that label of being
anti this is somebody who herself went
through a partial transition
now is anti-trans
she's not anti-trans she's just saying
look i'm just telling you a couple of
hours
is not enough time to make a decision of
this caliber
it's not enough time to make a decision
like this
but you can't talk about that right
because if you talk about that you have
to be willing to acknowledge that what's
going on is crazy right now
and they're pushing this stuff on kids
we've talked about the puberty blockers
we've talked about gender transition
surgery for kids is it now going to be
that you walk in you're a parent you
walk in with your kid and you sit for
counseling for two hours and your kid
can get all of these
drugs
and potentially a surgical transition
also if somebody that's 26 years old
that's also a very young person but if
somebody 26 years old could go through
something like that come out the other
side and say
i wasn't set in how i felt about this
what do you think of a 13 year old
they're not said in anything at 13.
everything is like fluid how they feel
about this how they feel about that you
don't think maybe that child
maybe who's been looking on the internet
on tick tock and says oh i feel out of
place maybe there's a kid out there that
feels out of place in their community
doesn't know what's going on maybe they
don't know their sexuality is kind of up
in the air they're confused 13 years old
thinking i don't know what i am i don't
know i don't fit in anywhere there's a
whole bunch of videos that you can pull
up and oh well this person transitioned
and felt better oh this person
transitioned and got well that's me let
me do that
you don't think that could happen of
course it can happen
you don't think that 13 year old could
change their mind in a few years and say
wait that wasn't what it was about
maybe it was about something else maybe
it was about my family maybe it was
about my sexuality but not not a desire
to transition think about what's going
on here and now you have these people
that have de-transitioned
that are
raising these warnings and and watch it
wait for it and watch they are going to
be ostracized
they are going to be ostracized some
have been already some of the people
that that were in the documentary that i
mentioned from matt walsh have already
been ostracized
already on twitter i see the comments oh
you're disloyal disloyal
these people remember these people are
telling their stories
they have a right to tell those stories
they're trying to help somebody
they're trying to help somebody out
there who may feel lost and all they're
saying is give yourself a second this is
a really big decision
it's not reversible in many ways it's it
changes your life in many ways please
think it through
please do more than two hours of a
counseling session before you make this
drastic decision
they're speaking to parents you don't
think they're speaking to parents of
course they are
they're saying just give it a pause give
it some time you there's a way to be
supportive
of what your child is going through
whatever it may be and not just a
knee-jerk reaction with something that's
medical with something that has
consequences with something that may not
be reversible
well and this chick was 21 when she
transitioned but uh
it's like you see in places like seattle
and oregon and you don't even have to
take your parents he'll be 13 years old
go to your doctor and your doctor's
legally required to give you and treat
you with um
transitioning care whatever the yeah and
what is the term is right what is that
really is it drugs is it now once you
start on the drugs you're then put into
counseling where whatever you thought is
being fortified which which you may not
be set on you may just be like think
about a child like i can't tell you how
many things have been said to me in
classrooms over the years
where kids are just kind of like
thinking out loud
now it's like oh well they thought
get them into a program
give it a second
this stuff and depending upon where you
live in the country tyler is right these
things sometimes can escalate very
quickly and parents oftentimes have no
idea what's going on
that's a scary reality for a parent
very very scary reality well and they've
they've run numbers on this and
once somebody transitions you have them
for life
and the amount of profit that the drug
companies and the pharmaceutical
companies can make off of one person who
transition is astounding right
absolutely astronomical right i i want
to say it's like
upwards of half a million dollars that
you can make off for these people yeah
of course because it's drugs you have to
once you start
if you're a biological woman you want to
become a man that's not you're not just
going to have a surgery and that's going
to happen you have to change your whole
hormonal composition or at least try to
and then you have to keep it there and
you have to keep it that way it's
ongoing prescription right so and that's
that's key about big pharma too is that
what you see on folding we just did a
segment about obesity
who benefits from that pharma
why because the population is sick after
that they're sick the population becomes
ill right you're more predisposed to
being chronically sick if you're obese
big pharma check maybe they'll be on
heart medicine huh check that's monthly
maybe their thyroid will not check
you know now you've got all this gender
stuff going on you think pharma doesn't
benefit of course they do that is a
lifetime guaranteed customer if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]